♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO THIS SPECIAL
EDITION OF "HANNITY."
ACT 2.
THE DEEP STATE'S DAY OF
RECKONING.
TONE  TONIGHT WE ARE INCHING
CLOSER TO REAL JUSTICE AND
HOLDING THOSE WHO ABUSE POWER AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR OVER 2 YEARS ON THIS
PROGRAM, WE WATCHED A POLITICAL
WITCH HUNT LIKE WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN IN AMERICAN POLITICS
BEFORE.
BASED ON LIES AND SMEARS AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
LIKE WE TOLD YOU ALL WEEK, THE
RUSSIA HOAX HAS UNRAVELLED.
THE MUELLER REPORT IS OVER, DEAD
AND BURIED.
WE HAD 4 SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS.
OH, THE FBI, HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
BIPARTISAN SENATE COMMITTEE AND
EVEN THE MUELLER REPORT.
NO COLLUSION, NO CONSPIRACY WITH
RUSSIA.
AS WE PREDICTED IT'S NOW
BOOMERANGING ON TO THOSE WHO DID
ABUSE POWER AND TRIED TO
INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME OF AN
ELECTION DOES OVERTURNED A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
ACT 1 IS OVER.
THE CURTAIN IS BEGINING TO RISE.
ACT 2 BEGINS.
A NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN AND HIS
NAME IS BILL BARR.
EARLIER TODAY HE WEIGHED IN ON
THE ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA PROBE.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> LIKE MANY OTHER PEOPLE
FAMILIAR WITH INTELLIGENCE
ACTIVITIES, I HAD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
I ASSUMED I WOULD GET ANSWERS
AND I HAVE NOT GOTTEN ANSWERS
THAT ARE SATISFACTORY.
IN FACT I HAVE MORE QUESTIONS.
SOME OF THE FACTS THAT I LEARNED
DON'T HANG TOGETHER WITH THE
OFFICIAL EXPLANATIONS OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> THAT'S ALL I WILL SAY.
THINGS ARE NOT JIVING.
>> Sean: ON THIS SHOW WE HAVE
BEEN HONEST FROM THE START AND
OVER 2 YEARS UNCOVERED THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN MODERN
POLITICAL HISTORY.
TONIGHT FOR YOU, WE HAVE
A SPECIAL SHOW.
WE HAVE BROUGHT IN TOGETHER THE
ALL-STAR ENSEMBLE CAST WHO
HELPED AMERICA GET TO THE TRUTH
AND EXPOSING THE SPYING SCANDAL
AND THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
WE WILL STICK TO THE FACTS AND
THE TRUTH HONEST.
WHEN THE 99% OF LIARS ABOUT THE
HOAX AND THE MEDIA MOB, AS THEY
CONTINUE TO BE WRONG, A RIGGED
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
CLINTON TO SAVE THEIR FAVORITE
CAN'T  CANDIDATE.
FISA ABUSE FRAUD.
CREATING A FRAUD ON A COURT.
USING SPIES AND INFORMANTS TO
DEEP STATE EFFORTS TO UNDERMINE
A PRESIDENT-ELECTED BY YOU.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS THEY
FIRST TRIED TO STEAL AN
ELECTION.
TONIGHT WE SHOT A SPOTLIGHT ON
THIS AND TAKE IT APART PIECE BY
PIECE.
WE ARE ONLY DAYS AWAY FROM THE
RELEASE OF MAJOR DOCUMENTS THAT
WILL ALL EXPOSE THE REAL
ELECTION SCANDAL, THE REAL
EFFORTS TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THE FISA APPLICATIONS AND GANG
OF 8 AND INTEL MATERIAL.
AN AVALANCHE IS COMING.
THE CASCADING DOWN OF TRUTH
FRUITY AMERICAN PEOPLE.
-- FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE HATE-TRUMP MEDIA MOB HAS
PUSHED LIES FOR 2.5 YEARS AGO.
THIS STARTED BECAUSE HILLARY
CLINTON SHOULD WIN 100 MILLION
TO ZERO.
IF YOU VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP,
YOU ARE A SMELLY WAL-MART VOTER
AND YOU CLING TO GOD, GUNS,
BIBLE AND RELIGION.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
THINKS OF US.
A MASSIVE AMOUNT OF TOP SECRET
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL WAS FOUND ON
HER UNSECURED PRIVATE SERVER IN
A MOM AND POP BATHROOM CLOSET.
THAT'S A CRIME.
SHE COMMITTED REAL FELONIES AND
HAD A CAREER INTENT WHEN SHE
DESTROYED THE EVIDENCE BY
DELETING 33,000 EMAILS.
BUSTING UP THE DEVICE AND
REMOVING SIM-CARDS.
REAL OBSTRUCTION WITH REAL
INTENTION.
THAT'S RIGHT.
ONE STANDARD FOR THE CLINTONS
AND ONE STANDARD FOR DEMOCRATS
AND ONE FOR ERVELT.
-- EVERYBODY ELSE.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
WE TALKED OFTEN ABOUT IT.
WHY WAS HILLARY CLINTON CLEARED?
WHY DID THEY RIG THAT
INVESTIGATION.
WHY DID COMEY AND STRZOK CHANGE
IT FROM THE LEGAL STANDARD OF
GROSS NEGLIGENCE TO EXTREME
CARELESSNESS?
THERE WAS CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT
THIS SECRET CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION WAS MISHANDLED AND
PUT ON A SERVER WHICH MADE IT
ILLEGAL.
MULTIPLE FELONIES.
CLEAR EVIDENCE SHE DESTROYED THE
33,000 SUBPOENAED EMAILS AND DID
ALL OF THE THINGS TO ELIMINATE
ALL OF THE EVIDENCE.
THE STRZOK AND PAGE TEXT ABOUT
THE TRUMP VOTERS.
THEY WERE THE LEAD
INVESTIGATIONS AND TURNED ON
DONALD TRUMP.
STRZOK INTERVIEWED CLINTON AND
ALLOWED TWO OTHER PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM AT THE SAME TIME.
THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
HE WAS WRITING HILLARY'S EXXO
EXXONONERATION IN MAY.
COMEY CLEARED ON JULY FIFTH.
-- NOT BEFORE MILLS WAS GRANTED
IMMUNITY AND THE TARMAC MEETING
WITH BILL CLINTON AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WHAT DID LYNCH KNOW?
STRZOK AND PAGE SAY LYNCH RIGGED
HILLARY CLINTON'S INVESTIGATION.
AN INJUSTICE.
WE WANT TO SAVE THIS GREAT
DEMOCRATIC NATION THAT SO MANY
SACRIFICED AND DIED FOR WE MUST
HAVE LEGAL APPLICATIONS FOR OUR
LAWS AND BE A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC.
AFTER CLINTON LOST.
ALL ROADS LEAD BACK TO THE DIRTY
RUSSIAN COLLUSION DOSSIER BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON.
THEN, A GUY, A FOREIGN NATIONAL
THAT PUT THESE RUSSIAN LIES
TOGETHER.
THEN THOSE RUSSIAN LIES BULK OF
INFORMATION THE NUNES MEMO TO
SPY NOT ONLY ON CARTER PAGE BUT
A BACK DOOR TO SPY ON ALL THINGS
TRUMP CAMPAIGN PUT TOGETHER BY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WHO DIDN'T
EVEN STANDBY HIS OWN WORK.
HE SAID I HAVE NO IDEA IF ANY OF
THIS IS TRUE.
HE WAS PAID BY FUSION GPS BUT
REALLY PAID BY HILLARY.
AND THE DOJ OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR,
HE WAS WARNING IN AUGUST OF
2016.
STEELE HATED TRUMP AND HILLARY
PAID FOR IT AND NONE IS
VERIFIED.
NOW EVEN THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
SAYS THE DOSSIER WAS
DISINFORMATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WROTE THE STORY THAT
KATHLEEN SOUNDED THE ALARM AFTER
MEETING WITH STEELE BEFORE THE
FIRST FISA APPLICATION WAS
SIGNED BY JIM COMEY.
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT WE HAVE BEEN
UNPEELING THE LAYERS OF THIS
ONION AND RIPPING THE MASK OFF
ALL OF THIS CORRUPTION TO GET TO
THE TRUTH TO EXPOSE WHAT
HAPPENED HERE. ASMT ATTEMPT TO